nightclubs in the nations are kissing
goodbye to a new year's countdown
as scotland wales and northern ireland
live under tougher restrictions imposed
by their leaders
dance floors will be deserted for a
second year running
the central club in wrexham won't just
be victim to major financial loss
but regular custom too we work all year
looking forward to doing a new year's
eve bash you know it's our biggest night
of the year it's our biggest money of
the year and now
you know that will carry us through the
quieter months of january and february
and now it's gone you know it's just
soul destroying i mean people are just
going over the border because it's five
minutes up the road for them
it's that which is a huge frustration
for businesses on the border
to see in the new year on a night out
people will be making the journey from
cardiff to bristol from edinburgh
to newcastle now from here in wrexham to
chester there will be no extra policing
it's a 15 minute journey and tickets are
only a fiver
[Music]
with no new restrictions in england yet
life here will be very different
compared to the other home nations and
whilst lenny's venue in wales will
suffer his bar in chester will be
buzzing we'll welcome the business we
are on the border of wales and obviously
people will come across to enjoy a night
out in chester and we're going to have
to be mindful in our venues to make sure
that we are trying to keep some social
distance with the pandemic continuum
the pandemic has shown us this virus has
no boundaries and as thousands are
expected to cross borders for
celebrations free of restrictions
a reminder that the nations of this
united kingdom move to their own rhythm
intimate rasheed sky news chester